is a big night for a group of 2021
graduates right here in las vegas rewind
one year ago
they were graduating in their cars at
las vegas motor speedway
tonight faith lutheran seniors got their
diplomas
in a once-in-a-lifetime ceremony at
allegiant stadium orco mana joining us
live there now with why
tonight's celebration was so very
memorable orca
well brian this was definitely a night
to remember for those faith lutheran
seniors
not only did they get to graduate inside
this state of the art stadium
but they got to do it safely together
[Music]
celebrating a major milestone in a truly
special setting
i'm feeling really excited it's finally
here nearly 300 faith lutheran seniors
the largest graduating class in school
history
filing into allegiant stadium friday
night for their graduation ceremony
it's my first time being here i was
walking over here looking at myself in
the in the reflection
and you just really get the full scale
of how big this place is so i'm really
glad
faith was able to put that together for
us we're told parents of the 2021
graduates raised the funds to use the
stadium when other venues were not
available but what's even more
magical is getting to enjoy the pomp and
circumstance in person
during the pandemic i was online most of
the year actually but it's really cool
being here with everyone all my
classmates
i think we're really lucky to be able to
be together as a class
and have this last moment
[Applause]
and with each name read and each diploma
given this is a night these teens will
never forget
once a crusader always a crusader now
there was of course physical distancing
for both the graduates on the field and
their loved ones in the stands
but again really just a really exciting
night for everyone here
reporting live from allegiant stadium
tonight orca mana 8 news now
so exciting orco and we also want to
honor